[Musique]
paris 26 août 1944 une foule en liesse
accompagne le général de Gaulle dans sa
descente des Champs-Élysées les
Parisiens fêtent la fin des 1524 jours
d'occupation ce moment fait déjà partie
de l'histoire il était attendu depuis
que les premières bonnes allemandes ont
foulé le pavé des rues de la capitale
c'est l'histoire de milliers d'hommes et
de femmes qui ont vécu y participer à
ces journées cruciales pour l'avenir de
la France
c'est l'histoire de Charles péguélu de
Revin qui a décidé de prendre les armes
pour libérer sa ville
de Jean Pietri soldat de la deuxième
division blindée qui a vécu la folle
course vers Paris au volant de cette
Jeep de Marciana Martin kovski fille de
résistant et de Gladys Thibault qui a
vécu son adolescence dans l'attente de
la Libération
c'est leur histoire que nous allons vous
raconter
19 août 1944 après plus de 4 ans
d'occupation Paris s'éveille et
s'insurge la résistance n'attendait que
ça à partir de 10 août policiers postier
cheminot ou encore ouvrier se sont mis
progressivement en grève nous sommes au
mois d'août 1944 il fait beau il fait
chaud et un petit peu comme aujourd'hui
les terrasses de café sont ouvertes
alors elles sont ouvertes évidemment aux
parisiens mais elles sont aussi ouvertes
aux occupants la pression je dirais
monte progressivement donc les Parisiens
se sont accommodés de cette situation
depuis plusieurs mois mais les
informations arrivent progressivement et
les Parisiens savent que les Alliés ont
débarqué en Normandie et progressent
vers la capitale donc il y a on va dire
une double tension la tension de la
météo du mois d'août et l'attention de
l'occupation allemande avec l'arrivée
progressive mais qui sont les
inéluctables des alliés de l'ouest vers
l'est
depuis quatre ans le quotidien de Gladys
Thibault 16 ans et rythmé par les
restrictions et la peur sous
l'Occupation la vie n'était pas facile
du tout du tout il y avait beaucoup de
tickets de ravitaillement fallait faire
la queue pendant des heures des heures
et des heures et on me disait souvent un
ou à ma maman ou à moi il y a plus rien
ma petite demoiselle il y a plus rien
vous avez fait la queue pour rien pour
se laver oh c'était très simple une fois
par mois tous les quatre dans la même
eau
le colonel real Tanguy commandant des
Forces Françaises de l'Intérieur en
Île-de-France lance finalement l'appel à
l'insurrection le 18 août des affiches
sont placardées au mur
le lendemain à 7h des policiers
pénètrent dans la préfecture de police
sans tirer un coup de feu depuis son
appartement rue Spontini dans le 16e
arrondissement Charles péguélu de Revin
18 ans apprend qu'il se passe des choses
sur l'île de la Cité il est décédé à
agir j'avais prévu la libération et
d'avoir un camouflé comment ce camoufler
mieux que d'être habillé en ouvrier
alors je vais acheter un bleu de travail
et me voilà parti vers l'hôtel de ville
et j'ai jamais pensé que il y avait les
patrouilles allemandes j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance d'en avoir beaucoup de chance
je dois l'avouer maintenant je vais te
débrouillé et j'étais armé
mairie d'arrondissement commissariat
ministère les points névralgiques
passent progressivement sur le contrôle
de la résistance qui connaît des
divisions internes old Tanguy ouvrier
communiste prend l'initiative de
déclencher l'insurrection tandis que les
gaullistes préfèrent atteindre l'arrivée
des Alliés une cause de vitesse s'engage
entre les résistants communistes et les
représentants du général de Gaulle alors
pour Eisenhower effectivement Larry
n'est pas un objectif stratégique ni un
objectif aux politiques c'est plutôt une
contrainte puisque dans son dans sa
planification des opérations et son
état-major l'objectif c'est de
contourner Paris soit par l'Ouest soit
par le sud pour poursuivre en fait les
opérations militaires jusqu'en Allemagne
les insurgés font parler la poudre
boulevard Saint-Michel à l'opéra au
jardin du Luxembourg ou encore au
Châtelet les munitions viennent à
manquer il faut négocier une trêve un
homme va jouer un rôle déterminant le
consul de Suède à
fait la liaison entre la résistance et
le général fancholtits gouverneur
militaire du groupe Paris
connu pour sa brutalité sur le front de
l'Est il a reçu des ordres préciditaires
Paris sera détruit s'il le faut
[Musique]
la trêve entre vigueur en fin de journée
roll tanguine ont prévenu veut continuer
à battre le fer de l'insurrection de son
côté Charles péguu de Revin est loin de
toutes ses considérations politiques il
traverse un pari désert il passe la nuit
en face de l'île de la cité dans un
bâtiment occupé par des policiers
20 août Paris ressemble à un no man's
land la trêve tient difficilement des
coups de feu sont entendus ici et là je
vais ôter de ville enfin je traverse et
puis
je tombe sur les études il y avait des
petits groupes
on a trouvé un inspecteur de police
qui avait les clés pour rentrer dans
l'hôtel de ville
alors on a fait passer sur le côté une
petite porte j'ai offert on est rentré
en toile de lire le bâtiment est
rapidement investi sans résistance 400
personnes s'y installent avec le comité
parisien de la Libération charles est un
des seuls à être armés il se retrouve
assuré la sécurité de réunion le
mouvement insurrectionnel est
difficilement contrôlable retourne
parole
la libération de Paris la prise hôtel de
ville n'est jamais entendu parler de la
prise hôtel de ville
un tableau on se croirait à la prise de
la Bastille les têtes coupées épique
dessus
la partie est loin d'être gagnée dans le
même temps à Vincennes 26 prisonniers
des gardiens de la paix majoritairement
son fusillés par des SS en déroute pour
défendre clairement les positions
conquises les Parisiens vont puiser dans
leur histoire symbole des révolutions du
siècle dernier des barricades
fleurissent dans Paris on retient
souvent le chiffre de 600 barricades qui
sont montés parfois de briquet de broc
un peu partout dans Paris elles n'ont
pas un rôle stratégique majeur
finalement parce qu'elle ne permettent
pas forcément
d'interdire les axes principaux aux
Allemands en revanche ça a une valeur
symbolique très forte
les ordres contradictoires se succèdent
la confusion s'installe l'état-major
effet fille d’île-de-france demande
d'éviter des actions contre les grands
monuments pour privilégier des actions
de harcèlement le même jour le Conseil
National de la Résistance se réunit dans
les souterrains de Denfert-Rochereau que
il est décidé que la trêve prendrait fin
le 22 août à 16h les insurgés au début
1500 sont désormais plus de 5000
parmi eux Marciana et ses parents ils
habitent à côté de la gare Montparnasse
son descendu les sacs de sable et puis
ils ont pris tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire pour effectivement faire les
barricades qui a été faite chez le
boulevard Montparnasse rue de Vaugirard
avenue du Maine ses parents sont
résistants à Libération Nord un des 8
grands mouvements de la Résistance ils
utilisent leur salon de coiffure comme
relais pour leur mouvement malgré son
jeune âge Marciana aide régulièrement
ses parents dans leur action clandestine
mon père étant d'origine polonaise
et ma mère d'origine flamande
ils ont eu beaucoup de difficultés à
voir la France vendue mon père a été
appelé par les gens de libération Nord
pour aider la résistance
Jean Moulin venait à la maison
c'est une plateforme pour les résistants
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
à Argentan le Général Leclerc
s'impatiente le commandant de la
deuxième division blindée n'a qu'une
obsession ces hommes doivent être les
premiers à rentrer dans Paris parmi eux
jean-pietri du régiment de marche de Spy
marocain un soir de mai 1943 il a sauté
dans un camion de recrutement Alger il
connaît l'épreuve du feu à la hutte un
carrefour entre Alençon et Le Mans on
pensait pas du tout au coup de fusil au
coup de canon qu'on allait recevoir
peut-être qu'on s'est dit de temps en
temps
est-ce qu'on va en sortir c'est possible
mais si on se le dit ça a commencé après
la hutte parce que là vraiment on a vu
qu'on échappait pas à la
un fusillade il y avait eu une mort à
cet endroit là
c'était là où on était vraiment dans la
guerre là on était dans le combat
et on avait toujours 20 ans
Leclerc décide d'envoyer un détachement
en reconnaissance au sud-ouest de Paris
il n'informe pas le général Bradley son
supérieur hiérarchique pendant que Jean
il ses compagnons d'armes attendent les
ordres à Paris la situation s'enlise le
22 août à 11h des camions allemands
essayent de forcer un barrage vers
l'hôtel de ville ils sont capturés un
représailles une colonne de chat
allemand se présente peu de temps après
dans le bâtiment c'est la stupeur je ne
bouge pas on ne tire pas qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait fait contre les chars rien et
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a toujours
un héros de service
[Musique]
l'étoile de Charcot en direction de
ville
et puis les ordres sont donnés
l'hôtel de ville on n'aurait pas pesé
cher
les charmes tirent finalement qu'un obus
qui rafle le coin du bâtiment et font
demi-tour au même moment de violences
affrontements éclate dans le 20e
arrondissement une trentaine d'Allemands
sont tués
face à l'insistance du général de Gaulle
qui craint un bain de sang et une prise
de pouvoir des communistes dans le même
temps fancholtits reçoit un ordre
d'Hitler il doit défendre Paris jusqu'au
dernier homme le gouverneur du grosse
Paris a fait piéger les vieux
emblématiques pourtant il hésite à
suivre les ordres au même moment Leclerc
reçoit le feu vert le 22 août à 18h la
deuxième dB s'élance le lendemain matin
à 6h 15000 soldats 4000 véhicules et 400
chars couvrent 200 km en une quinzaine
d'heures
on frottait les mêmes parce qu'on allait
mettre la la belle raclée aux Allemands
maintenant
on était en phase 2
c'était fini la rigolade on jubilé bien
sûr parce que c'est plus on était plus
dans le
certitude
la certitude c'était qu'on allait à
Paris
voilà quel chemin on allait prendre pour
y arriver
combien de temps mettrait
personne ne savait et d'ailleurs
personne se posait la question
pour la deuxième dB c'est une journée
prend des airs de défiler victorieux son
avance est parfois ralentie par
l'enthousiasme populaire à Paris la
journée du 23 août est marquée par
plusieurs affrontements des chars
allemands attaquent le poste de police
du Grand Palais qui s'embrasse le temps
presse le 24 août l'ordre d'opération du
Général Leclerc et limpide sans parait
de Paris la progression est plus
difficile que prévu les canons allemands
positionnés dans la banlieue Sud font
des ravages la division Leclerc compte
71 morts et 35 chars des touris c'était
l'aventure on savait pas où on allait on
était sur la route en général
on le peloton sevait un ordre un moment
pour faire telle progression dans le
quart d'heure qui suivait on courait
après les Allemands
le soir la division est bloquée aux
portes de Paris Leclerc s'agace à 18h30
il fait survoler l'île de la cité par un
avion qui largue le message suivant
tenait bon nous arrivons à 19h30 un
carrefour du village d'Antony il
interpelle un certain capitaine drone
qui commande la 9e compagnie du Régiment
de marche du Tchad surnommé la Nueve
elle est composée majoritairement de
républicains espagnols Leclerc lui
ordonne de foncer jusqu'au centre de
Paris
l'idée c'est d'entrer dans Paris et de
montrer justement qu'il est ce bras armé
du général de Gaulle de la France en
général pour prendre position de Paris
avant les Américains donc l'ambition de
Leclerc si bien de t'entraîner dans
Paris et de prendre contact avec les
résistants et de prendre contact avec la
population parisienne il s'agit aussi de
de se montrer tout simplement se montrer
en fait auprès des Parisiens de se
montrer auprès de l'autorité
littéralement pour dire que finalement
pour eux et bien c'est la fin d'une
aventure c'est la fin de l'occupation de
Paris par les Allemands le capitaine
drone progresse rapidement en évitant
les Allemands avec l'aide de la
population ils pénètre dans la ville par
la porte d'Italie à 21h22 le convoi de
150 hommes coupe les moteurs place de
l'Hôtel de Ville les cloches de
Notre-Dame et de tout Paris se met à
sonner au revoir arriver ces gens
ce matériel parce qu'ils avaient les
alphas
et puis
en uniforme avec des armes et tout c'est
un c'est formidable
mais pour nous on s'est dit maintenant
ouf on est tranquille parce que même si
les amours reviennent ils vont tomber
sur un os
le 25 l'ensemble de la deuxième dB et la
quatrième division d'infanterie
américaine entre dans Paris par les
portes d'Italie de Gentilly d'Orléans et
de Sèvres nous ne savions rien en
ouvrant mes volets il y avait un
monsieur qui passait dans la rue il me
regarde il me dit mademoiselle on est
libéré je suis dit c'est pas vrai il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas il me dit si
si on est libéré on a fait des bisous
filles à la Porte de Saint-Cloud
il faut pas croire que c'était dans un
seul sens et nous on voulait un peu de
mécaniques bien sûr parce qu'on était
on pensait qu'on était pour beaucoup
dans ce dans cette situation
il y avait beaucoup de
d'amitié il y avait une chaleur qui
explosait de nos coeurs en disant ils ne
sont plus là on va vivre autrement et
nous avons gagné
[Musique]
c'est l'effervescence la progression des
blindés aussi entre embrassades et
violons affrontements
de participer à quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
la libération de la France c'est pas
tous les jours ça se passe
c'est pas c'est pas tout c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on débarque en Normandie
pour aller se retrouver à la frontière
alsacienne
il y a eu aussi les gens il faut pas
l'oublier
qui avait probablement eu conduite doute
pendant l'Occupation
et qui cherchait à la faire oublier
cette conduite c'était difficile de les
remettre en place parce qu'on n'était
pas là nous c'était quand même abject de
voir ce qui se passait de gens qui
n'avaient rien fait
et qui se sont mis à régler des comptes
qui étaient des contes factices il y a
une blanchisseuse rue d'Alençon elle a
été on lui a rasé la tête
parce que elle avait gardé un jeune
allemand
chez elle
en fait c'était un jeune allemand qui ne
voulait plus faire la guerre et qu'elle
a caché c'est une vieille dame
ils l'ont prise
ils l'ont rasé
mes parents étaient outrés de voir ce
qui se passait
si bien que cette dame
elle n'est jamais sorti sans cheveux car
toute la nuit mes parents ont préparé
une perruque
là encore école militaire pas les
Bourbon Sénat hôtel Majestic ou encore
place de la République la division
perdra 45 hommes ce jour-là pendant que
ces hommes combattent Leclerc pénètre
dans Paris peu avant 10h et installe son
PC gare mon Parnasse quand l'armée
Leclerc est arrivée il fallait aussi
trouver des places
si bien qu'ils avaient ouvert le salon
pour qu'il se nettoie qu'il se fasse
leur toilettes faut quand même pas
oublier quand ils sont arrivés il y
avait rien à Paris il fallait les loger
il fallait leur donner à manger il
fallait quand même et ça on oublie de le
dire pendant plusieurs jours le salon de
coiffure devient un lieu de passage
incontournable du quartier pour les
soldats de la deuxième des baies le
Général Leclerc m'a donné une boîte de
conserve j'ai mangé un caramel
comme j'avais pas mangé de sucre pendant
4 ans
et bien mais fait d'armes c'est que j'ai
vomi sur les genoux du Général Leclerc
Leclerc envoie un ultimatum aux
autorités allemandes qui restent l'être
morte l'hôtel Meurice qui héberge le
gouverneur du grosses Paris est pris
d'assaut à 13h une fois capturé et
conduit à la préfecture à 15h20 où il
signe la reddition avec Leclerc
roll Tanguy demande à signer l'acte de
reddition pour faire reconnaître le rôle
de la résistance Funchal teats est
ensuite emmené à la gare Montparnasse où
il reçoit un comité d'accueil où le
quand
l'officier allemand est venu signer ma
mère s'est précipitée
et elle lui a craché la figure en lui
disant voilà ça c'est pour les les
soldats que vous avez acquis vous avez
craché en 40 c'est un retour des choses
de Gaulle entre finalement dans Paris à
17h alors que des combats font encore
rage il prend connaissance de la
reddition gare Montparnasse et se dirige
ensuite à l'Hôtel de Brienne siège du
ministère de la guerre après un rapide
passage à la préfecture de police il
sera à l'hôtel de ville où il prononce
un discours pour l'histoire devant 200
000 Parisiens
Marie Paris ou Tanger
paris brisé Paris bactérisé mais Paris
libéré
libéré par lui-même libéré par son
peuple avec le concours des armées de la
France avec la pluie et le concours de
la France tout entière j'avoue que
j'étais extraordinaire
les mots qu'il a eu et puis le on était
vraiment pris
je suis redescendu c'était mon grand
[Applaudissements]
avec un autre désigne que vous ne
connais pas d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
protéger deux boules j'ai eu la
sensation de dire enfin
de dire enfin on a un patron là HS on va
voir faire quelque chose et cette
libération va devenir une vraie
libération
26 août Paris est en liesse c'est la
grand-messe de liberté retrouvée enfin
presque la deuxième dB même des
opérations pour sécuriser la banlieue
nord de Paris les affrontements
continueront jusqu'au 29 août nous à la
gare du Nord nous n'avons été libérés
qu'à la fin parce que tous les Allemands
passaient devant chez nous plasmajata
entre les Allemands qui étaient toujours
là près de nous n'est-ce pas et puis
qu'ils partent vous avez pu on en était
on s'est dit ils vont peut-être venir
la situation est encore instable mais
cela n'empêchera pas Paris de célébrer
sa libération les Champs-Élysées restent
le point incontournable la plus belle
avenue du monde de Paris même à l'époque
et le fait de conduire se déplacement
jusqu'à notre âme c'est quelque chose de
très fort dans l'imaginaire français
Gaulle est investi d'une mission qui
pour lui est essentielle c'est de
montrer justement que la souveraineté
française et de nouveau là que la France
est là malgré le concours des alliés ce
ne sont pas les alliés qui vont imposer
une manière de faire une manière de voir
une manière de conduire et de reprendre
le dessin de la France
c'est la panique
le chef de la France Libre reste
impassible nous avons fait un petit tour
ou Champs-Élysées avec mes parents nous
y sommes allés pour dire oui nous sommes
libérés et nous étions rudes il y avait
des Allemands qui résistaient le risque
est là Paris sera bombardé durant la
nuit au total plus de 1000 civils et FFI
ont trouvé la mort pour libérer la
capitale mais l'insouciance est plus
forte on a toujours des amis qui ont des
bonnes idées elle me disent ben voilà on
va aller aux Champs-Élysées et puis on
va essayer de monter dans une jupe
c'était très agréable croyez-moi d'être
toute seule dans cette vie il était
superbe j'étais jeune
je pense que j'étais content de moi
d'avoir été de cela
[Musique]
et même à 18 ans et demi
avec seulement son bac
on doit pouvoir se rendre compte de ça
mais c'est quand on regarde après tout
tout ce qui s'est passé pendant cette
période ont été les événements marquants
on a risqué de perdre la vie tous les
jours tous les jours
Paris est libre mais la guerre est loin
d'être finie
Charles s'engage dans la deuxième DP il
ira jusqu'au nid d'aigle d'Hitler à
berchengen
pendant plusieurs années des privations
empêcheront Gladys de reprendre une vie
normale
Marciana devra affronter le retour des
siens des camps de concentration
Jean qui rencontre sa femme pendant ses
jours de permission à Paris combattra
jusqu'à Strasbourg
ces destins ne sont que quatre histoires
parmi les millions que comptes la
libération de la France
[Musique]